someone finally succeeded in the series
finale of succession and it was an
unexpected turn to say the least one of
the show's Stars has a theory as to why
shiv Roy voted to make things happen the
way they did warning spoilers for the
series finale of succession ahead a new
CEO of waystar royco was vested with
power during the series finale and the
new top dog was a definite curveball Tom
womsganz played with oily Perfection by
Emmy winner Matthew mcfadian after
Kendall shiv and Roman Roy all try and
fail to secure their late father Logan's
vacant Throne it's Tom who takes over as
the American CEO when way star royco
goes ahead with its sail to Gojo and its
billionaire leader Lucas Matson for a
man who's been belittled in numerous
ways throughout the series this is
certainly a meteoric rise for Tom no
offered to go to jail Tom you offered
because you're servile you're just
you're servile in the end it's shiv
played by Sarah snook that propels Tom
to the top spot though Matson originally
promises the CEO spot to her he goes
back on that promise and chooses Tom
it's shiv's tie-breaking vote in the big
board meeting that allows the sale to
happen when variety's Kate Arthur noted
that shiv helped Tom get to the top
mcfadian offered a Counterpoint saying
it's interesting that because a lot of
people have said that but that was never
in my head and I don't know what Sarah
thinks but I don't think it was anything
to do with helping Tom Tom does tell
shiv earlier in the finale that it will
be him if the Gojo deal is voted through
but mcfadian thinks the decision had
little to do with Tom and everything to
do with shiv's disgust for Kendall
mcfadian continued I don't know because
it's Sarah's thing but I think it's just
that she can't stomach her brother she
goes to the board meeting to vote to
block the deal and also she's just been
royally betrayed by Matson there's
something in her that snaps or that sort
of curdles when she sees him stand up
her brother as CEO and make that speech
and she can't do it I don't think it's
calculated don't think it's like oh I
can align myself with Tom yeah I think
it's just like jerks awake she's changed
her mind snook hasn't weighed in so
there's no way to know what the actress
was thinking about shiv's motivations
but based on the scene she shares with
Jeremy Strong's Kendall before the vote
mcfadians take definitely makes sense
when shiv tells her brother she can no
longer Back Him Kendall absolutely loses
his mind I'm the youngest boy
oh I am the oldest boy so now that the
smoke has cleared it's worth asking if
Tom actually won despite him getting a
big position of power it kind of seems
like a bad deal for him first of all he
and shiv are clearly staying together
despite the fact that they really seem
to hate each other most of the time
their horrible reluctant depressing
handhold as they ride away after the
board meeting beautifully reveals the
years of resentment and bitterness to
come Beyond his flailing marriage Tom
also has to deal with Madsen during a
dinner behind shiv's back where Matson
asks Tom to be his pain sponge and a
front man Tom tells the Gojo owner I
have a very very high tolerance for pain
and physical discomfort Matson also
bluntly tells Tom that he wants to sleep
with shiv on top of everything both
companies seem kind of doomed Gojo has
been badly inflating its numbers and
waystar royco is nothing more than a
bunch of broken parts according to
Matson nobody was ever going to win on
succession and it could be argued that
Tom lost most of all as mcfadian put it
it's a funny thing because it's not
winning anything I mean that's sort of
missing the point by a million miles not
to be literal but it's like winning what
it's just another move in a corporate
nightmare at least Tom will have the
real love of his life his disgusting
brother by his side he ultimately
forgives cousin Greg the Sky High
buffoon played by Nicholas Braun even
after Greg tells Kendall the news about
Matson passing over shiva's CEO in that
same Variety article mcfadian talked
about why he thinks Tom actually kind of
looks up to Greg explaining I think he
likes having Greg around he recognizes a
kindred spirit in Greg they're both
Outsiders and they've both taken a lot
of from everybody even though Tom
would never admit that and I think Tom
sort of admires Greg in A demented
Mentor Way
[Music]
thank you